the first story we have here from
timkes.com twitter board utilizes poison
pill to stop elon musk from buying the
company the plan intends to reduce the
likelihood that any entity person or
group gains control of twitter check
this out you guys know how this works
kind of so this is if elon musk tries to
buy up more than 15 of the company
they're going to offer special stock to
the other investors at a discount rate
so they can dilute the equity power that
elon would have meaning no matter how
much he buys the other investors can buy
up and take away the power he's buying
they're they're effectively
destroying their own company to stop
elon musk from ending their censorship
wow yeah that's probably because the uh
the saudi arabian king is involved with
prince
prince as well the saudi arabian state
as well so i imagine it's all good
elaborate i know there's a prince who
who invested the prince tweeted out and
it also said that the state itself he
said the kingdom
is that just his company or well to be
honest to be fair i don't know i assume
that that was the kingdom itself yeah i
saw uh zero hedge tweeted that he
actually sold his shares i don't know if
that's true
the prince hold his shares i don't know
if that's true it's hard to know but i
think the uh the big play here is the
people who own twitter as we mentioned
the other day and and what we can get
into now
they want the power the political power
of twitter to control the conversation
saudi's aside i think it's vanguard
vanguard upped their stake to to say now
we own more than elon so there's some
very nefarious corporate interests that
want control of this mouthpiece that is
twitter
what do you guys think vanguard and uh
blackrock have a pretty substantial
disney steak as well mm-hmm yeah
interesting they also own group
deliciousness which is weird yeah like
they own two percent of the other
it's important
yeah yeah definitely sorry i had to go
there that's true it's a little inbred
when it comes to the money so here's
here's the crazy thing right let me ask
you this question brett do you use
twitter a lot yeah have you always used
twitter a lot no only this year see
because only this year it's only for a
few months i know as of last so in the
last year it was like early 2021 and you
are 20 years old
gen z
and you're only recently getting
involved in twitter yep twitter is
it's like the political space right like
how do your friends feel about it
younger people honestly it is not the
most used i think instagram and tick
tock are just what is most heavily
dominated in politics everybody is on
twitter so my friends that are in the
political sphere they are very active
but outside of that people have like a
burner account basically where they go
to just look at memes but they don't
tweet anything they're not involved it's
kind of like oh yeah i'll check twitter
but it's a very thing in normal circles
that's kind of outdated like oh yeah
it's just whatever and i never really
had a a reason or an interest in being
on it until i started i was writing for
fee and they were like you need to be on
there to you know promote your articles
and that kind of stuff
um but that's a that's not even true
yeah
so when i worked at fusion they were
they didn't have twitter uh i think it's
been a while but we had a conversation
about how
you know websites like to put the social
media link so you can tweet out the
story post post the stories and they
didn't care about twitter and ask them
why they said twitter doesn't drive
traffic
and so i was like okay for me i was like
twitter is really important but back in
the day when it was the free speech wing
of the free speech party it was really
important
now like i mentioned i'll post like a
picture of a hairless rabbit for no
reason and just just post nonsense
because the platform is garbage
twitter's kind of like the repository
social media network i
signed up in oa didn't use it till night
2019 because i thought it was crap but
it's youtube is where it's at the video
makes you famous and then they come and
follow you on twitter when they find out
you have a twitter account no one finds
you on twitter that's not how it works i
mean maybe not no one but it's not well
people found me on twitter when they
realized that i looked like bench peers
that's where i got the bulk of mine i
had like 400 followers and then jeremy
retweeted the side by side of me and ben
and it was like okay now you have twenty
thousand wow okay pinch wheat on your
account right now yeah you can go check
it out i'm bringing people people were
chatting female ben shapiro
but uh you're taller
i am yeah yeah ben's actually not that
short that's the funny thing yeah you
know we just hung out with him the other
day and i i'm like everybody says he's
short and then he walks up to me i'm
like oh he's actually a fairly average
like totally normal guy that's they just
they just like lying and making things
up because they want to hate on people
but anyway back to the reason i was
asking you these questions twitter's a
failing company
like
yo we're i'm 36 ian's 75
you're like good thanks you look good
yeah no but like in all seriousness
we're we're an older demographic and you
have to get
young people involved in in your culture
if you want that culture to persist
twitter seems to be on a train track
that leads just flying off a cliff
they're not they're not convincing young
people to be involved in what twitter is
they have turned twitter into an
activist blog yo i called this
i said several years ago and they were
banning all the fun people the trolls
and the silliness and the memes i was
like dude it's going to turn into a
left-wing activist blog it's going to
have 10 people and events will be one
guy and some people might visit it
but so why would a young person want to
go on a platform to be lectured by old
fogies complaining about policy yeah
yeah instagram and i think instagram and
tick tock you mentioned is it's pictures
and video i mean it's video for the most
part twitter's text it's a lot of text
you know you go there to read and
research essentially but not to have fun
i don't know is it fun for you i mean i
enjoy it because for my show
which is technically me diving into
comment sections and that kind of thing
i use it's my i know uh it it's the
i go into the trenches my friends um it
is it's the hub of my research basically
so i enjoy it because but most of the
stuff that i'm looking at is like you
know batshit crazy things and so i
personally enjoy it but i wouldn't go on
there if this wasn't like my work i
would probably choose tick tock i would
choose youtube yeah i would but it used
to be fun people would go on and they'd
post memes they'd ship memes like crazy
and they would uh troll yeah trolling
was fun and then we get this like the
ceo now uh parag agrawal he's like you
know it's not about free speech it's
about this the current state of things
and having a healthy conversation and
it's like dude if i wanted to go
to like a youth seminar where they
explained to me you know morals or
something sure i'd book it
if i want to go and just
post my thoughts and tell people like
here's a funny joke you can't do that on
twitter anymore so what do you do you
got to go somewhere else what about
reddit is reddit still i use reddit
sometimes but how are they with
censorship like oh it's the worst i was
going to say that's what i've heard i
know that yeah dude that used to be you
know what it is it's like it's like it
feels like
it like the school principle has taken
over the social media platforms yeah and
it's like we used to
you know throw bouncing balls down the
hall and then run after it now the
principal's in the hallway all day going
like hey you don't know that we're like
this is so lame let's go somewhere else
lauren southern tweeted out that it was
like only five years ago that if someone
got banned off of youtube or twitter it
was like global news and now geez
you blink and then like a bunch of
accounts are gone i don't know who's the
most recent band does it even matter but
it's just it's disturbing how slippery
the slope can be remember remember how
fun alex jones was yes
so yeah was there a point where you ever
used twitter in any even a little bit
before never probably
and that's that's that's the thing i
think where you know i look at the elon
musk stuff and i'm just like dude
twitter is blowing itself up on purpose
yeah it has to be because that was
another thing that i felt with elon that
it's like
i love what he's doing the statement
that he's making but i also kind of had
the opinion like it already is like
you're saying a sinking ship there's so
much other crap that's going on in the
world there's so many communities that
need us that i mean you know everything
else and it's like this is great but
also no he's right elon musk is right
yeah he he posted the top 10 twitter
accounts that some of them haven't even
posted this year like justin bieber or
whatever yeah because the platform is
dead yeah there's users on it they gain
a little bit of users dude
you know we were talking to jeremy about
this and he's like hey i said i don't
even take it seriously anymore i used to
post news stories now it's like i just
bro i i post like chicken city is some
great accomplishment because i'm just
i'm like
it's a it's a garbage platform filled
with garbage people who just want to
just they rag on you they lie about you
they smear you
there's no good conversations there's no
fun there's no jokes you'll get banned
for saying learn to code i don't take it
seriously
and then you know he's like you have a
million followers though and i'm like i
don't i don't know why but i actually do
know why it's what you said youtube fame
well people will watch these shows and
then they'll follow on twitter because
they want to just like see their news
feed and see information but i can't
take a platform seriously if it's dying
and it is
i i can gain followers i'll put it this
way let's say there's a hundred million
people that are using the site at any
moment sure i have a million followers
so i can lose a bunch and gain a bunch
within that sphere but it feels like the
sphere of actual
functioning
valuable users is just going down yeah
elon said it was like the town square
and that's why he wants to buy it to
free it i don't know if he's right about
that it doesn't i'm on it a little bit
but it's such a small kind of like the
bathroom stall wall it feels like yeah
more than the town i wonder if him just
saying okay forget it i'm not buying it
let it fail might be the right move then
try and waste energy and time pouring
all this money into some you know
relatively dying platform it'd be cool
if you could free the software code but
we really don't need it what would be
the town square though
yeah i guess i think so what do you
think it's not centralized there's
there's disparate communities the thing
about twitter is it's really easy to
overlap with different groups so you
know ben was mentioning that he trends
once every three weeks
and it's because one of his tweets will
merge into another community which will
then
go nuts about it youtube doesn't do that
youtube is much more uh rigid
you know like if you don't get you don't
get shown like stuff
is outside
you can't retube
yeah yeah
and so they used to have that your
channel page you could post stuff on
your channel page and all your followers
would see your channel post so i was
like 2007
i think you can still do that if you
like community yeah yeah you like stuff
and and but youtube can't capture that
so twitter became this rapid it became
political because it's
what are you posting or posting ideas
youtube you're posting videos instagram
you're posting photos so it makes sense
that the platform that typically is
about text idea concepts information
would become political news some of the
highest level stuff the problem is
twitter sought to
light itself on fire burn itself to the
ground and make it a trash platform that
nobody wants to use i thought it was a
doomed from the beginning i i 2008
there's videos of me in 2008 when all
the people like hey this new thing it's
twitter i'm like oh great another one we
just did facebook we already have
youtube what are you guys doing we just
have we have our
and they're like we're going to tweet
our message our six word messages to
each other i'm like dude text is gonna
warp our minds don't fall into it i i
agree disagree especially with the text
swapping your mind but disagree on the
prospects of twitter when it for when i
started using it i think i signed up in
2009 i was like what's the big deal with
this and then within a little while i
was like whoa
now i get it yeah the rapid virality
like you you tweet something and if it's
good information if it's a funny joke it
ripples out way outward in a massive
wave that gets bigger that little pebble
you drop can become a tsunami remember
that woman who was on a plane and she
made that joke about aids oh my gosh and
then like her phone was off and then
when she landed they destroyed her life
she had like 200 followers do you ever
hear this story
this lady had like 200 followers and
then she made a joke about how
white people tend not to get aids in
africa but it was actually a social
justice joke the point she was making
was that
the people who are who are mostly
victimized by this tend to be black and
she said it in a tongue-in-cheek way
this was like one of the first major
cancellations i think the tweet went
viral and she was just some like
random woman
and she lands and she like had a panic
attack everyone she was there were news
news stories written about her they were
going nuts
you know what ends up happening is
people like there's this viral threat
going around
explaining how elon musk will not be
able to save the platform because he
doesn't understand that web web 1.0 is
over the era of the wild west internet
is gone
and this guy explains that
in the beginning of the internet it was
it was the frontier it was a barren
wastelands yeah you can go out into the
middle of a barren wasteland and scream
whatever stupid ridiculous nonsense you
want because they nobody's gonna hear it
eventually some people show up and then
those who don't like hearing the crazy
guy in the desert screaming leave and
those who think it's funny stick around
and watch
but where we're at now with the internet
the foundations have been built it's not
just the frontier anymore it's it's it's
totally urbanized the internet now is
the world you can't just go into the
middle of the city and start screaming
insane things the cops will come and
tell you to keep it down they'll say you
have your free speech you can't scream
people will come and scream back at you
a fight might break out and so what this
guy is saying is because of that
censorship emerges and he's like the
only thing the big tech platforms want
is for you to calm the f down be civil
and i'm reading this and i'm like dudes
write about the frontier thing wrong
about the censorship and what they want
they the the people at twitter
are all biased
not every single person i mean like the
higher ups they are they think they're
not they are it's baked into their rules
they will ban you for calling someone
dude like when they suspended zooby
and this makes it not fun and if you're
not having fun you're doing it wrong i
don't wan i i'll put it this way
how many of you
on your day off would decide to go
somewhere so that someone can scream in
your face about how ugly you are
you'd be like ah no i'll just go to the
movies instead right
that's what twitter has become
by
eliminating the fun
and by
the they are they're outright bias
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you